NICK: Wren...
WREN: So I... I noticed that there was this little M&M
peeking out of this trail mix bag,
and I thought it was a dart-- a little Nerf dart.
I was like, "Ah, there's a Nerf dart! Oh, it's just an M&M."
And then Nick got to looking at it and he was like,
"Why is there, like, a random little nibbled hole in this bag?"
So check this out:
what does this look like to you?
I don't want to make any broad statements but we have so many rats right now.
BEN: [shouting] What!?
NICK: We have rats, dude. Or mice.
[Cut to clip from Scary Movie 3]
MAN 1: Rats are outside, mice are inside.
MAN 2: Yo, but what if a mouse goes outside? Does it become a rat?
And if a rat is in the house, is it a mouse?
MAN 1: I ain't seen no mouse outside, that's what I'm sayin'.
MAN 2: That's because it's a rat, fool!
BEN: No, that's just how Carmichael eats.
WREN: For what it's worth, I've never seen any rodents here.
We don't have any other evidence.
BEN: Worst case scenario, how does this play out?
We're all dead in 6 months, is what it means.
NICK: Yeah.
WREN: What do you think this is?
BRETT: It looks like bite marks, son.
WREN: What do you think caused that hole?
SAM: Munchkins.
NICK: So we're gonna set up a a time lapse
overnight and see if we can catch any
mice or rats or...
...Peters, or...
...whatever it may be.
[Keyboard clicking]
NICK: There's 2,000 photos. It was going all night.
Watch the M&Ms... and they moved.
That leads me to believe... Oh!
NICK: [gasps] Oh!
WREN: Oh, there it-- yeah! Wait, wait, wait, wait wait--
ALL: [exclaiming]
NICK: Dude!
CARMICHAEL (?): There's a rat in the office!
BRETT: Shit, there is a rat, dude.
NICK: He lives on my desk, dude? That's not sanitary! Holy shit!
WREN: You have a rat livin' on your desk, bro.
NICK: Dude!
CARMICHAEL: Dude, he's huge!
CARMICHAEL: The rat is as big as this cup!
BRETT: [calmly] You were right, son. You were right.
CARMICHAEL: What the hell are you dressed like that for!?
BRETT: Dude, I am a goon, son.
WREN: Oh my god, I can't believe it, dude.
It... worked!
NICK: [laughter]
CARMICHAEL: Take a snapchat!
NICK: Does he live over here...?
CARMICHAEL: Does he climb up there...?
NICK: He makes multiple trips.
WREN: You can see him eatin'!
NICK: Dude, he's pretty cute.
Wren: Well, let's see if he, uhh... [tapping keys]
...ever comes back...
CARMICHAEL: D'you wanna see the rat?
NIKO: [laughter]
JAKE: You got it on timelapse!?
WREN: Yeah! We got it on camera, man!
JAKE: Oh, there it is.
NIKO: Whoa!
JAKE: [softly] our little fucker.
NIKO: Look at that little cute guy.
NIKO: Why was Nick recording a timelapse of the corner of his desk?
WREN: To... To catch the... the rat.
JAKE: To catch the rat.
JAKE: Let's-- we need to put a bounty on its head.
What, 20 bucks?
NIKO: [eating] I decree that whoever catches the rat...
...shall get a 6-pack of any beer of their choice!
CARMICHAEL: [laughter]
JAKE: Alright, deal.
CARMICHAEL:
SAM: You're gonna lead me into a dark room.
Is this a trick?
SAM: I have no idea what this is.
This is just an ambush.
[Paper crinkling]
SAM: Wow.
Son of a bitch.
SPENCER: It's-- it's tiles and terrain.
This is the modular stuff, so it's actually super awesome.
It's the city-builder stuff.
SAM: All their previous sets came in just, kind of-- just general squares.
You'd just slide them together.
But their latest set comes with
very, very, very well-designed...
...basically, posts, as you can see here.
These things plug into the walls here
and allow you to create structures
You can do multiple stories,
You can do rooms...
SPENCER: So right here, it's drapes for the window.
SAM: ...frickin' nerd. Frickin' got drapes.
I would literally never buy real drapes.
But I would get miniature drapes any day.
SPENCER: [laughter]
SAM: Honestly, I'm just totally blown away.
I wanna give a huge shout-out to Dwarven Forge.
Thanks, guys, for, uh, getting us some of this gear,
and I cannot wait to start using this in videos.
If you guys haven't checked out their site, do it now.
They make the best stuff.
NIKO: So we have a mouse living in our house.
It's been chewed out here... There's a bunch of dust all over the...
...ground here from it.
I happen to have... two very good mousetraps next door.
They go by the names of Corri and Roto.
NICK: Niko just alerted me that Jan is coming by.
[Nerf gun clicking]
[Sounds of a pitched Nerf battle]
JAN: I could use some support!
JAN: Yes!
JAN: God--!
Right in the knuckle!
WREN: [laughter]
WOMAN: I'm getting good, I'm totally gonna win, and then he shot me in the face.
JAN: [out of breath] Hi, guys, how's it going? [laughter]
NIKO: Ah, I got shot right in the neck.
[imitates a bullet impact] Aah!
CARMICHAEL: Now, with the rat running around
and, now, Corri hunting it somewhere in the studio,
I figured I could make a rat trap.
For this DIY rat trap, we're going to need a few things.
This rod that I found.
[Rod clatters to the workbench]
Peanut butter.
Nice little water bucket.
This is gonna be my pilot hole.
[Drill whirring]
[Hi there, Nick]
CARMICHAEL: Ta-da!
[Drill whirring]
CARMICHAEL: So, we're not gonna drown the rat.
Instead, it's just gonna go... to the farm!
Where our first two cats live...
...and all the Peters live...
[Dremel buzzing]
NICK: Hey, there we go.
CARMICHAEL: Yay!
NICK: We're ready to smear peanut butter all over this bottle.
CARMICHAEL: Yep.
NICK: Do we have any peanut butter?
CARMICHAEL: We do have peanut butter. It's right in front of you.
NICK: Ayyyy.
NICK: Aw, man. Why d'you gotta do that, man?
You just got peanut butter everywhere.
NICK: Don't-- dude, really, though?
No, you clean it up!
BEN: Oh, god!
CARMICHAEL: [laughter]
NICK: [exclaiming]
WREN: There was a fly in my wine I was drinkin' last night.
I had to spit it out on the table.
BEN: [haughty voice] While I was having a fine vintage, a...
NICK and CARMICHAEL: [laughter]
BEN: ...airborne insect made its way into my esophageal tract.
WREN: I tounged it, man!
WREN: [imitating a dying fly]
NICK: Nothin'.
NICK: Did you check it?
CARMICHAEL: Yeah. The time laps shows that he... wasn't even there
There's one last thing to do.
Go to Amazon...
CARMICHAEL: I-- I hope this is the big one.
NICK: So, Carmichael bought some rat traps, and we set 'em around, and it's been a couple days now, but...
...ehh, there's nothin'.
We put out four of them: two upstairs, one here,
and then one in between me and Carmichael's desks where we found the rat.
Niko thinks the rat has literally just left the studio since we took away all the food.
Maybe we'll... we'll never catch him. That's probably for the best for all of us.
[Rat squeaking]
[Squeaking continues]
[Sniffing]
[Romantic harp sound effect]
NICK: Carmichael, what happened?
CARMICHAEL: I got it!
NICK: Is it ali-- it's dead?
CARMICHAEL: It's so big!
WREN: He's, like, dead.
NIKO: People might give us some crap for
using a lethal rat trap.
Let's be honest. It's a rodent.
They spread disease.
They put poop everywhere.
If they get into your food, they can make you very sick.
Also, for what it's worth, it's a humane rat trap.
Meaning, there are spikes and the bar, and when the bar closes on that rat,
it's going to instantly just break its spine,
and pretty much... [snaps] lights out instantly.
[Rat trap snaps closed]
NIKO: Well, that... That's a pretty solid ident in that pencil.
That's pretty much an instant guillotine for a rat.
Now we have to clean it up! [laughter]
CARMICHAEL: You know what we should do now?
Watch our favorite Disney movie, Ratatouille.
NICK: That's not my favorite.
NICK: Alright.
CARMICHAEL: Lesson learned?
NIKO: Rat traps work.
NICK: Confirmed.